what's up YouTube as you can see I'm in
HD for those of you who don't know what
I do for living aside from school music
and comedy I work in a black beauty
supply store namely my parents own one I
got a lot of people about this but they
don't believe me so I took the time to
go ahead and document it on my iPhone
yeah and the first type of people that I
want to show you are the Jolly Rancher
hoodrats and why do I call them Jolly
Ranchers the red is because they wear
the brightest colors known to man and I
kid you not they are always the biggest
women the hugest ones the most huge the
only positive about them wearing bright
colors is the fact that I could probably
see what's coming at me if they fall
over you know baby
you don't believe me check it out
for the green one I don't even know what
to say she look like a big old sack of
Shrek and on top of that her ass is a
liar like literally her ass is lying
because it's just pink on the back of it
she's dressed like a bottle of
pepto-bismol but she's giving me stomach
aches so I really don't know how that
works out this is this is what I called
the gang of hood rats talking to each
other and having a conversation and I
want you to listen carefully to what
they're saying because even I didn't
know what the hell they were talking
about and this is just a little side
note this I actually got a clip I
actually recorded one of them that was
really close to me and I wanted you to
see what she was wearing she look like a
ghetto Hamburglar if some people last
like how do I record them is simple what
I do is I kind of possible arms like
this I'll just kind of casually just act
like I'm texting somebody I'm not
texting no texting anyways I have the
second webisode coming out and I know I
said I was gonna come out probably a
little bit while back but it's taking a
while because I just got my new
equipment I just got the new camera I
got the new mics I got the lights I got
the the whole shoulder rig so you so my
camera bag and hold it up the script is
all written out everything's done we
just got to get a film and I just gotta
go ahead and edit in stuff like that so
stay posted for the dating game the next
episode coming out after that it's gonna
be really funny too I don't want to
spoil it but you're gonna laugh your ass
off and if you don't I hate you guys
playing don't unsubscribe
according only Asian people Park like
this baby if I turn this way perfect
[Music]